what if i don't win i just want her to
love them so much my nuggets are gonna
be fantastic energy's gonna be the
reason why i win i am really gonna try
to make this plate look pretty for inga
fingers crossed spice it up
[Music]
hello it's inka and today i am
challenging three cooks to spice up a
mystery dish which is chicken mcnuggets
i love chicken nuggets i think they're
perfect as is i'm really curious to know
how people would jazz it up they have 45
minutes to come up with something and
then at the very end i'll pick my
favorite let's see who can spice it up
the best
hi i'm alexis and today i'm going to
make my version of chicken nuggets my
boyfriend said that these chicken
nuggets were like the best he's ever had
i don't know what inga wants or is
looking for but these are truly the best
i've ever had so for my chicken nuggets
i'm going to start by grinding my own
meat i'm using chicken breasts and i'm
just gonna blot them dry with paper
towels that's just to get any like extra
moisture off and the reason that i'm
grinding these myself is because when
you do that you have more control over
what's in it obviously there's not like
other spices or preservatives no extra
water content in there and also that
means i can control the texture and the
size more i just want to cut these into
like half inch cubes so the reason that
i'm putting the chicken on the parchment
paper lined baking sheet is because i'm
gonna actually throw it in the freezer
for like 20 minutes so you don't need it
like totally like ice cube frozen you
just want it to be frozen enough that
it's gonna blend and get chunky back
with my frozen chicken and the food
processor blade which i also had in the
freezer and that's just again to like
help it get to the right consistency so
you can see that this chicken it's like
yeah it comes off the parchment paper
super easily it's like hard but not like
rock hard pop it in the food processor
bowl when dealing with raw chicken it is
very important to wash your hands okay
so chicken in the bowl and i'm gonna add
some heavy cream and i've got rosemary
thyme oregano salt looks like a lot of
salt but it's chicken breast you need
salt and pepper
i don't like big chunks but i do want
some like uneven texture it does look
like cat food right now but just bear
with me great i'm ready to shape my
chicken nuggets okay my chicken mixture
i've got another parchment paper lined
baking sheet so just take like a heaping
tablespoon and put it on the baking
sheet you can make them in any shape and
that's really the joy of it okay i've
got all my chicken nugget shapes i think
they look really cute i'm gonna pop
these in the freezer and then i'm gonna
make the sauce what are chicken nuggets
without sauce there's so many good sauce
options but today i'm gonna make a
barbecue mayo super simple it's mayo
barbecue sauce smoked paprika the smoked
paprika is gonna give it a little kick
and it's just going to add like a little
depth of flavor
if i was a spice i'd be cardamom my
boyfriend says i use cardamom in
everything and that is true but i think
it's just such a nice like again depth
of flavor okay i think this is like
sufficiently stirred it looks so good i
would love to put my finger in it but
this is for inga so i'm just gonna put
it in the fridge i'm gonna do a classic
dredging situation for my chicken
nuggets i've got flour here got salt and
pepper again just gonna add a little
more flavor i feel like with something
like chicken breast you really want to
add that extra salt and extra flavor
some really beautiful eggs and then i've
got panko first into the flour and
whenever you're dredging you just want
to make sure that you know you get like
excess flour off excess egg so that it's
not like a big weird flour chunk that
gets fried i think you could totally
bake them you're making a chicken nugget
it's not like the time to really be like
so health conscious right i've heated my
oil to 350 degrees and i'm gonna fry my
nuggets for a few minutes until they're
golden brown and hit 165 in the middle
that's like the temperature you want
chicken to be cooked at and these are
just like slowly frying they look great
that's like the perfect nugget have you
ever seen something more perfect i feel
so proud of these chicken nuggets and i
feel like they are the best even if i
don't win
i feel like she's gonna love them i'm
sorry to everyone else this is perfect i
love it
okay i think at this point it's just up
to anger so fingers crossed
hi i'm kanchon so i'm gonna turn indian
inspired chicken kebabs into nuggets i
grew up eating these chicken kebabs they
were my grandmother's recipe passed down
through the ages it's been a long time
since i had some mcnuggets but i
remember them pretty fondly so we're
roughly chopping some chicken and
putting it into a food processor so to
our roughly chopped chicken we are going
to add some red onion garlic
ginger
fresh cilantro and mint then we're going
in with garam masala garam masala is a
traditional indian spice blend it has a
bunch of beautiful spices like cardamom
and cloves and cinnamon cumin coriander
it adds warmth peppery notes kind of
earthiness it's just a match made in
heaven for kebabs and then for heat
because it's all about spicing it up we
are going to add some cayenne pepper and
we're just going to finish this with a
generous sprinkling of salt and pepper
okay so now we're just going to pulse
this until we have a kind of kebab
nugget mixture if there is such a thing
if there isn't such a thing there will
be after today now it's time to shape
our nuggets we want to go in with wet
hands so it prevents sticking as we
shape the nuggets so we're going for
that classic kind of flatish roundish no
shape shape you also want to have it not
too thick so that it fries up quickly
now we're just gonna freeze our nuggets
for one to two hours
the secret to an award-winning chicken
nugget is an award-winning sauce so we
are going to make a chutney inspired
kind of ranch dressing to the food
processor i'm adding some greek yogurt
more fresh cilantro to really bring out
those flavors in the kebab nuggets fresh
mint leaves jalapeno peppers garlic lime
juice
sugar to balance things out and salt and
pepper and we're just going to blend
this until smooth adding water if
necessary i grew up eating this green
chutney on sandwiches with tomatoes i
grew up dipping these kebabs in this
green chutney so this is a really nice
way to kind of pay homage to my
childhood cool we're going to make our
dry mix and our wet batter so we can fry
these kebab nuggets to my dry mixture
i'm going to add all-purpose flour
potato starch potato starch will add
crispiness like it does to the
traditional japanese fried chicken
karage so that's my little trick for
crispy nuggets and then we're just gonna
add onion powder garlic powder sumac for
kind of tangy lemony earthy notes and a
little bit more heat with cayenne pepper
and to this i'm just gonna add a little
bit more salt really hoping that potato
starch works its crispy magic so for our
wet mix we are going to add two eggs
water and some more potato starch we're
gonna mix this really well and now we're
ready to
bread and fry our nuggets so now that we
have our frozen nuggets we're just going
to take our nuggets dip them in our dry
mixture pop them into the wet batter i'm
going to use one hand for wet one hand
for dry that way i don't make a gooey
mess and we end in the dry and fry if i
were a spice i would be the child of
sumac and like red chili powder or
cayenne i just love the heat from the
chili and the sort of lemony fruity
earthy tang from sumac these are all
breaded and ready for frying we're just
gonna pop these nuggets into our hot oil
all right we got some crispy brown
action we are ready to take them out ooh
nice and golden brown i really wonder
what my grandmother would think if she
knew i turned her kebabs into mcnuggets
i feel like she'd be pretty pleased
we're gonna start by plating our dipping
sauce our chutney ranch dressing that's
just what i'm calling it and of course
we're gonna top it with some spices
we're spicing things up so we have a
little dusting of cumin some coriander
and some more of that spicy cayenne
pepper and we're going to try to plate
these beautifully and tantalize inga's
taste buds visually
there we have it garam masala
chicken mcnuggets
what it do everybody my name is ross
panetta i am the chef and owner fight
kitchen and i will be making spicy
nuggets what makes my spicy nuggets
spicy spices and you know a certain
ingredient that not a lot of people are
fond of or
know about that's msg
monosodium glutamate is like a food
additive it is a flavor enhancer and you
know a lot of people have this negative
connotation that's like it's bad for you
but you know anything in excess is bad
for you a little bit of love goes a long
way pretty much we're gonna go ahead and
start with our ground chicken i'm using
ground chicken thighs here it is the
juicier part of the chicken you can use
chicken breasts but i feel like it gets
weird after you like fry it too much and
then it gets like dry and stuff
fantastic all right so we're gonna use
this spat you know pat it down give it
some love we're gonna throw in some salt
throw in some paprika some kanjan
cayenne pepper call it kenjan in the
kitchen this is white pepper this is
gonna make it crazy some black pepper
onion and garlic powder and then i'm
just gonna mix this up real quick before
i add the flavor booster all right cool
bam msg energy's gonna be the reason why
i win
it's like a little kick you know just
wanna add some happiness and joy to your
life it is dredge time guys got some
cornstarch here this is the best way to
make something crunchy without just
using regular ap4 i feel like people
should have this stuff in their crib
then i got some potato starch gives a
nice texture this is my regular ap flour
throw it in there we're gonna add all
the spices in this dredge because you
want to have all the same flavors except
that msg throw some salt in there garlic
powder onion powder white pepper black
pepper paprika whisk it all up if i was
a spice what would i be
we have some all my best friends i'm the
saltiest person you'll ever meet because
i sweat a lot and i'm always upset at
something we're gonna be dredging our
chicken two times making a mess
my chefs would be proud of me so now
we're gonna form some chicken nugget
patties get my hands some water and form
some nuggets so we're going to set them
on that tray talk about life how your
grandmother won the lotto the other day
which didn't give you any money now that
our nugget patty things have been formed
so we're going to go ahead and chill
this for about 20 minutes i forgot my uh
my spicy apron bam so we gotta work on
our batter i got eggs here my golden
whisk because we bougie i'm gonna throw
in your buttermilk so all you want to do
is make sure that your buttermilk and
your eggs are fully incorporated because
this will be the key to success we have
these two trays of the drive dredge and
i'm stuttering right now because i'm so
nervous because i want these to come out
so well take one in your first tray
you're gonna dust it ever so so kindly
and lightly you know just want to treat
it with some love quickly dip it in your
egg mixture with the buttermilk because
buttermilk and chicken go together like
lamb and tuna fish if anybody gets that
reference i will love you forever we're
gonna dip it in the second one or an
even coat and we're gonna transfer it
over to our tray we're gonna repeat this
as many much times as you have pieces of
chicken and then we're done now they're
all floured and nice and we're ready to
set them in the fridge so now we're
going to build our sauce you know i'm a
big fan of mayonnaise but i'm a bigger
fan of kewpie mayonnaise what is cupid
mayonnaise keeping mayonnaise is
mayonnaise that is pretty much egg
yolk-based and has msg in it i got some
ketchup and pickle juice because you
know sweet sour salty spice it up got
some white pepper white pepper is
something that a lot of people don't
really use it is very pungent it's very
pungent smelling this is the consistency
you want it's drippy and it looks good
this is done we're going to do a double
fry guys we're double frying because one
we would like it to be extra crispy so
we're going to go ahead and fry these
and then remember don't drop it like
it's hot you're going to drop it like
it's not hot because you don't want to
burn yourself and the reason why i'm
moving them around is because you don't
want them to stick to each other but
yeah these are getting nice and crunchy
they're floating so that means you know
a lot of things are cooking on inside
they're getting nice and not raw anymore
nuggets are done with their initial fry
i can only fit five in this spider over
here i'm going to lay them over milo
milo's gonna come back up to 350 for the
final fry the second fry is the shorter
fry so we did the first initial fry
about six or seven minutes it's gonna be
about like two and a half to three
depending on like i said how big your
nuggets are or how hot your oil is or
how fast it goes down yada yada
sometimes you're going to get these like
nice little really dark deep brown parts
but that's fine that's all flavor the
nuggets are looking fantabulous anyway
so now we're going to lay it back on our
paper towel but we're going to go ahead
and try these we're going to go ahead
and plate go ahead and arrange our
nuggets like we're feeding the president
so cheers to you all my nugget lovers
out there
[Music]
oh my god these are good that is our
nuggets spicy nuggets because we're
spicing it up
we have
these three beautiful plates of nuggets
here i guess i'm just going to start
here for this one i can already smell
like even from here i can smell the
spice first bite i'm just going to dunk
it in the sauce
[Music]
this one has so much flavor oh my
goodness oh it's just super super
fragrant i'm also not used to seeing
like so much color going on in here
crushed great flavor great okay moving
on oh okay this one beautiful crust
good crunch the sauce is like sweet and
tangy
tastes great with the sauce tastes great
without the sauce okay moving on to our
last one but i'm gonna dip it in here
mmm there's a bit of a kick to it which
i love look at how juicy that is dear
lord overall fantastic nugget i have
come to a decision so let's bring
everyone back and we will share who the
winner is
[Music]
thank you all for coming today they were
all so great the first one i tried had
incredible flavor so many spices went
into it the second one beautiful panko
crust amazing mouth feel and texture the
third one the heat of it and just like
so juicy but this is my winner
i was like wait that doesn't look
familiar
everybody try it amazing this is the
best you're gonna go i've ever had
this is incredible i'd like to thank god
and my dad produced me how to cook and
my love for nuggets thank you guys
that's it for today tell us in the
comments what we should spice up next
otherwise we will see you next time
[Music]